On a morning and the second week of March,
1857.
Okay.
Americans grew up living,
they didn't all quite understand it yet,
but that grew up living in the land of the dred Scott decision.
And if you were African American,
that really meant something.
No,
1857 is of course,
the final year of the playing out of bleeding Kansas.
And we'll return to that in just a second.
And we're going to discuss mostly today,
uh,
the story of one abolitionist.
You could say the most famous abolitionist,
certainly the most notorious American abolitionist,
John Brown.
John Brown never made it easy for people to love him.
In some ways,
he wasn't very lovable
until he died on the gallows.
And the gallows made him heroic,
at least to some people.
And it made him all but the devil to others.
There are catalytic events in history that is events around which ideas,
forces,
movements,
problems,
coalesce.
Unfortunately,
they often have a lot to do with violence.
And we'll come back to this point to Dan today,
but John Brown was far,
far,
far more important dead than he'd ever been alive.
Poets,
songwriters,
lyricists,
biographers,
those who would come to loving those who would come to hate him.
And those who cannot quite figure out what to do with him would never stop
writing about him.
And we still haven't.
And we're in the midst right now of John Brown biography revival.
That's in part because next year is the hundred and 50th anniversary of the
harpers ferry raid.
Almost all major African American poets in the 20th Century attempted there John
Brown poem.
It's Soda Soda,
Steven Vinson,
Venay and I famous and classic lyric epic poem called John Brown's body
published in the 1920s and embedded in that poem is this verse we're Benet I
think captured.
Okay.
The dilemma of John Brown,
John Brown is not easy to decide
was he a heroic revolutionary
or a midnight terrorist.
This is [inaudible] verse embedded in a 250 page epic poem.
The law is our yard stick and it measures well or well enough when they're our
yards to measure,
measure a wave with it,
measure fire,
cut sorrow up in inches,
way content.
You can wait John Brown's body well enough,
but how and in what balance do you way John Brown,
he had no gift for life,
no gift to bring life,
but his body in a cutting edge and he knew
how to die
more on old John Brown coming up
the year before John Brown's raid,
the most important,
the most exhilarating and by far than all those substantively interesting
political debates in American history would occur in Illinois.
And Abraham Lincoln runs for the u s Senate against Stephen Douglas,
even Douglas,
same Stephen Douglas author,
the Kansas Nebraska act parliamentarian genius of the compromise of 1850 the man
most associated with the Democratic Party's theory of popular sovereignty for
Kansas and Nebraska and the whole of the West.
And this Guy Abe Lincoln with one term in the US House of Representatives and
then a failed attempted reelection.
Okay.
A guy with very little experience when he ran for president
in the opening of his campaign,
he decided to open it in the legislative hall of the Old State House and
Illinois.
It's on the outside steps of that state house where Barack Obama began his
campaign almost exactly a year ago,
but inside Lincoln gave his now famous house divided speech.
Now in your reader,
your Lincoln reader edited by Mike Johnson,
you have the house divided speech,
but read past the first page.
Okay?
Don't just read that first lyrical biblical paragraph.
Read what Lincoln goes on to argue the speeches about the dred Scott decision.
Yeah.
This beaches is his opposition to the dreads get to the Supreme Court case has
just been passed the year before his speeches,
his opposition to the Kansas Nebraska Act,
his speeches,
a warning.
It's the warning of a moderate Republican.
Nevertheless,
a moderate antislavery free soil republican
who throws down the gauntlet in the wake of dred Scott.
This is a sentence on the fifth page of the house divided speech.
Page 68 and your reader,
if you'll look it up,
we shall lie down soon,
said Abraham Lincoln pleasantly dreaming that the people of Missouri are on the
verge of making their state free and we shall awake the next morning to the
reality instead that the Supreme Court has made Illinois a slave state,
get his drift,
dred Scott decision in his view and the view now most in this new extraordinary
coalition,
the Republican Party believed the dred Scott decision now threatens everybody
north,
south and west
with the presence of slavery and slave labor and all that goes with it.
It's the opening of that speech though of course that the world always remembers
and we love to return to this in our political culture,
in our political history,
whenever we feel great polarization and great division,
are we a house divided again against ourselves?
If we could first and know where we are and whether we are tending this is so
Lincoln,
he kinda Manders and a bit of a home spun way into a very serious argument.
We could then better judge what to do and how to do it.
We are now far into the fifth years since a policy was initiated.
Kansas,
Nebraska with the avowed object and confident promise and putting it in to the
slavery,
agitation
under the operation of that policy,
that agitation is not only not cease,
but has constantly or augmented in my opinion,
and will not cease until a crisis shall had been reached and passed.
A house divided against itself cannot stand.
I believe this government cannot endure permanently,
half slave and half free.
I did not expect the union to be dissolved.
I do not expect the house to fall,
but I do expect it will cease to be divided.
It will become all one thing or all the other southerners never forgot that
sentence.
Either.
The opponents of slavery will arrest the further spread of it and place it where
the public mind shall rest in the belief that it is in the course of ultimate
extinction and those two words more than else Lincoln had uttered before the
civil war.
Southern Democrats would never forget or it's advocates will push it forward
until it shall become a like lawful and all the states old as well as new north
as well as south have we no tendency to the ladder condition.
Let anyone who doubts carefully contemplate that now almost complete legal
combination piece of machinery so to speak.
And here he's arguing the slave power conspiracy without naming it compounded of
the Nebraska doctrine and the dred Scott decision.
Let him consider not only what work the machinery is adapted to do and how and
the machinery and how well adapted,
but also let him study the history of its construction and trace if he can or
rather fail,
if he can,
to trace the evidences of design and concert of action among its chief bosses
from the beginning.
Okay.
It's all there.
The Republican Party coalition of ideas and fears is all there,
but what was everybody's so angry about?
What were the dred Scott Decision?
It's just a supreme court decision.
Well,
I left you the other day hanging in the balance.
Dred Scott,
was this a Serta and old old man?
By the time this thing finally got before the ship got on the docket in 1854
finally,
it was argued in late 1856 and early 1857 and when the court brought down his
decision,
literally two days,
I believe,
48 hours after the inauguration of James Buchanan is president in 1857
okay.
His case was now his name would now become almost a household word across the
country.
Okay.
No.
A measure of how important this case was as it was developing largely illegal
secrecy was the kind of lawyers who argued it.
Montgomery Blair and George Tickner.
Curtis for Scott Montgomery,
Blair with come with the famous Blair family from Missouri and moderate
antislavery leaning Republicans by this point in time,
member of Congress,
George Tickner,
Curtis,
a former attorney general of very important famous trial lawyer.
Okay.
And for the government and other former us attorney general remedy Johnson and a
u s senator Henry Guyer,
where the lawyers,
okay.
Brevity.
Johnson made the startling statements in the arguments,
the supreme court and called for a pronounced.
He made startling staves and he called for a broader pronouncement from the
court.
He urged Justice Tawney,
the chief justice and the court to render a big decision here and try once and
for all the put this late as Lincoln it slavery,
agitation,
this whole slavery in the Western territory.
His problem to rest supreme court I after all is supreme.
Okay.
Remedy Johnson said,
I quote him.
This is the case.
The shell determine whether slavery shall live forever for ever.
Whether it preservation of slavery was the only way to preserve the union.
Okay.
The decision came on the sixth of the March,
1857 and here was the decision Tani and the majority in the court did not have
to go as far as they did.
This is now legendary and famous Tawney developing his majority and it was
ultimately a six to three decision.
Unless you think the supreme court doesn't really matter in our political
history,
please remember the dred Scott decision number one,
part of the,
there were three parts of the decision.
The first was jurisdiction.
Did dred Scott as a black person have the right to sue.
That's just the first question they were asked to,
to settle the right to sue for anything in a federal court.
Could a noncitizen
because he was a negro,
which is the language used.
Then sue in federal court
two
did Scott's residents on free soil.
Remember is four years with Dr. Emerson is former owner from 1834 to eight and
38 living in Minnesota territory.
Did his residence on free soil entitle him to freedom
or if a slave was taken by his owner to free states or free territory's?
Was that the law of the state?
The master came from that always had jurisdiction.
In other words,
was it the law of Missouri that took precedent here.
Okay.
Or the law of Minnesota.
Yeah,
and the third question before the court,
they didn't have to take this one up,
but they sure did.
Was Congress's right to determine slavery in the Western territory?
Yeah,
the pressure's on the court were tremendous,
as I said,
to move for a broad decision to try and put this thing to rest.
Well,
the decision of course six to three
and at that point there were five southern born justices,
five either slave holders or former slave holders on the supreme court.
The six judge who voted with them was Greer of Pennsylvania forming a majority
against the three northern born justices who voted against it.
The decision was one,
Scott had no right to sue in a federal court to his residence on free soil,
did not give him his freedom.
The law of Missouri was in place and third,
and by far most important the court rule trying to put the rest now nearly 40
years of this problem that had been compromised this way and compromise that way
and argued with that principle and that principle and that principle.
As we've seen it ruled the congress had no authority to exclude slavery from any
u s territory because it would be just as southerners had been arguing now for
two generations,
a violation of the fifth amendment to the constitution.
A person's right to life,
liberty,
and property.
If someone ever wants to doubt that American history is about its ironies,
just note that language.
Therefore,
the Missouri compromise line that's Oh called sacred pledge that had now been
violated,
said northerners and the Kansas Nebraska Act had never been constitutional to
begin with.
Then any attempt to prevent slavery's expansion anywhere
would be unconstitutional.
Now,
tawny not only went that far,
but in his opinion and his own written opinion,
he famously went a step further and he argued or he said quote that blacks or
Negroes,
the word he used had four I'm quoting,
had for more than a century,
been regarded as beings of an inferior order so far inferior that they had no
rights,
which the white man was bound to respect.
MMM.
Some of the most infamous words ever in an American Supreme Court decision.
Now
the decision is six to three was issued
for this new Republican Party coalition and the north.
And in some ways this was horrible news and in some ways it was good political
news cause nothing crystallize this Republican coalition now quite like this
case.
Yeah.
They will crystallize and resistance to it as I just tried to demonstrate from
quoting from Lincoln's house divided speech.
But most importantly here,
I'd argue,
I mean the hook to hang your hat on here.
Is it the dred Scott Decision?
It's not once and for all.
The war is not necessarily now inevitable contingencies are always there.
They're always laying there to happen.
But what the dred Scott decision did almost once and for all,
is that it destroyed compromise.
It destroyed almost any conception now of consensus or compromise or put another
way it ruined moderation.
Moderate politicians,
former Democrats like David will muck from Pennsylvania racist to the core,
but free soiler who's joined the Republican Party,
Abraham Lincoln,
Illinois.
MMM.
Got his own racial problems,
but a much more advanced sort of antislavery thinker,
but still a moderate.
He didn't like abolition is he'd never been a member of an abolitionist society.
Never would be
believe there were concert institution,
constitutional restraints on what Congress could actually do about slavery,
but it will bring together now some strange bedfellows in this Republican
coalition
who cannot find anymore any middle ground would their photos.
And that's when you see danger.
You just think you're more than see danger in American political history.
It's when the side that loses a debate cannot accept the result.
No.
There are many ways to try to demonstrate the importance of that dred Scott Case
as it's sunk in now,
it's sinking in now in the summer of 1857 as a depression hits the country wages
in America,
north in northern cities like New York,
Boston,
Philadelphia,
and so on.
Drop 40 and 50% in six months.
The estimate is that 100,000 workers in New York City were thrown out of work by
the end of 1857
about 50,000 in Philadelphia,
uh,
prices of wheat go plummeting practically overnight.
The United States had one of its first significant stock market crashes.
There's a lot to be feared here and on both sides of this north and south,
they're going to blame each other.
Southerners are going to blame northerners for over speculation,
for the overfishing of credit by banks.
And of course they're right about that.
There were no controls on banks in these years.
It was no federal deposit insurance corporation.
You only got that from the new deal in the 20th century.
Yeah.
And Northern,
there's going to blame southerners
because of their belief in king cotton and this kind of dependence on a single
export.
I think I'll throw blame all over the place.
If you are African American,
you now live in the land of the dred Scott decision,
which had said what?
It said,
you will never be a citizen of the United States.
You have no rights,
which the white man has to respect,
which means the white man's constitution,
which means the white men society.
It means you live in the land of the dred Scott decision that said,
you have no future in the United States.
Okay.
In the wake of the dred Scott Case,
about a month after it,
Frederick Douglass gave a speech,
which was a bit uncustomary for him.
Uh,
and the 1850 [inaudible] Frederick Douglass was learning his politics.
He really was learning.
He was getting his feet as a political thinker and even as a politician,
he was trying to sidle up to this Republican Party.
Don't know.
It was kind of a half baked loaf of bread to him.
It wasn't real.
Abolitionism
this case drove him further into their laps,
but he gave a speech largely to a black audience and the way could dred Scott
and so typical of Douglass's brilliance is in order.
He started to discuss how he saw fear on the horizon and trouble and dread on
the horizon,
and he said he saw what he called the manifold discouragements of my people.
Everywhere I go,
I quote him.
They fling their broad and gloomy shadows across the pathway of every thoughtful
colored man in this country.
And then he ended with this lament.
I see them.
These are discouragements.
I see them clearly and feel them.
Sadly,
with an earnest Dakin Hart,
I have long looked for the realization of the hope of my people standing as it
were barefoot and treading upon the sharpened flinty rocks of the present and
looking out upon the boundless see of the future.
I have sought in my humble way to penetrate the intervene in your intervening
myths and clouds and per chance to see in the distance of time at which the
cruel bondage of my people should somehow in and the long and tuned millions
rise from their file grave of slavery and death.
But of that time I can now know nothing and you can know nothing in all is
uncertain at this point.
Our walk by faith and not by sight.
Yeah,
that's Douglas as beautiful and terrible way of expressing that he's now told is
an African American.
You have no future in the United States.
All right,
so who was John Brown?
MMM,
that picture.
I'm going to show you just a couple of images here.
John Brown of course,
has been a fascination for artists to say the least.
I don't want to take too much time with this,
but this is a black and white version.
I don't know if you can see the rope up here.
This is one of the 22 panels and Jacob Lawrence's magnificent series on John
Brown.
Jacob Lawrence,
the great African American painter.
He painted this in the 1930s
in at least 20 of the 22 images in Lawrence's incredible series on John Brown,
you will find some image of a crucifix
of
execution.
The hanging,
when I was teaching at Amherst College,
I don't know,
eight or nine years ago,
we had Jacob Lawrence for an honorary degree
and I got to spend like two days with him.
It was one of the greatest thrills of my life.
And uh,
the museum at Amorous managed to get the,
the series on John Brown.
They had it in a room and I was asked to do a gallery talk on it.
And so I went into the room the day before I was to give this talk all by
myself,
nobody in there.
And I just commune with these terrible images.
Sometimes the images sort of crisscross bayonets and sometimes criss cross
rifles.
And sometimes it's literally crosses on the wall in rooms.
And sometimes it's this image brown hanging.
Yeah.
And I was overwhelmed by it.
And the next day I gave this talk and I talked about these images of crucifixes.
What they hadn't told me is that they were also inviting a busload of fifth
graders to come to the lecture.
And they also hadn't told me that that morning and the New York Times and the
headline today is wouldn't even get headlines.
There'd been a bus bombing in Jerusalem and 38 people were slaughtered in a bus
by a terrorist bomb.
And I was going to talk about John Brown,
whether he was a terrorist and walk the fifth graders,
toughest.
Dot.
One of the toughest audiences I ever had.
How do you smooth over John Brown and all those crucifixes the fifth graders on
a field trip?
Don't even try.
Just the answer
now.
Their favorite image in mind of John Brown's,
David Levine's David Levine as the artist for the New York review of books.
It's actually comes from 1969 a series of books had come out and John Brown,
I mean this is an image that kind of fits brown to many people.
The gardens,
you know,
Kinda wild man.
He's got red face,
probably big nose gun belt bullets all around him kind of saying don't mess with
me.
But then of course there's
Thomas Hovenden
incredible painting of John Brown,
which hangs in the Metropolitan Museum of art in New York.
Um,
I don't have the full version of it.
Yeah.
This is the painting that depicts the scene of John Brown leaving his jail cell
and Charles Town Virginia on the day of his execution.
Okay.
According to the artist with the hangman's noose already around his neck before
you even wrote to the gallows details.
And a black woman comes up with her baby and raises her baby to John Brown and
he kisses trial.
It's the legend of the kiss is John Greenleaf.
Whittier put it in a poem that didn't happen,
but
in art,
anything can happen.
This is the gentle savior,
John Brown.
This is the liberator,
This is the murderer,
John Brown.
There are many,
many,
many John Brown's.
Yeah.
And you're going to start hearing about and seeing a lot more of them next year.
Um,
oh gosh.
Does that backward?
No,
I guess that's not bad.
You can't see that very well,
but so be it.
Well,
John Brown was
born in Connecticut.
Uh,
Torrington to be exact and just our ways up the road,
um,
is born in 1800 [inaudible].
He grew up mostly out in the western reserve as it was called of Ohio.
He witnessed at the age of 12,
the beating of a slave boy.
There were remnants of slaves don't traversing the north and the 18 teens.
Okay.
He tried divinity school for a little while at the age of 16,
but said he quit because of insufficient funds.
And because all the reading caused him sore eyes,
he experienced a confession of faith in his father's church.
Congregational old fashioned Calvin is congregational church.
When he was about 16,
he married first in 18,
21st wife would die on him.
Yeah.
He had no less than 20 children by two wives over some 30 years.
Nine of those children would die in infancy
from 1822 1855 he engaged in approximately 20 different business ventures of one
kind and another in six different northern states,
virtually all of which ended in failure and poverty for his family,
several of which ended in lawsuits and bankruptcies and one litigation after
another,
one of which led to debtor's prison for a while.
He and his family had to live a poverty stricken,
rolling stone existence across the northern states.
Probably what sustained him,
and we know good deal about this was his religion,
his faith,
his theology if you want.
He was a kind of orthodox in 19th century Calvinist.
He believed in such things as a Nate depravity,
providential designs,
predestination on some level and the total human dependence on a sovereign and
arbitrary God and an arbitrary God that sometimes chose certain individual human
beings in history to act for him.
Okay.
He believed in an old testament kind of justice and I for nine a tooth for a
tooth.
He punished his children and his employees with mosaic vengeance.
He had a puritanical obsession with the wickedness of other people.
He could be domineering vein obstinate as one friend once put it impervious to a
joke,
probably not a lot of fun to just have lunch with.
Okay.
He gave orders,
remembered Brown's younger brother quote like a king against tune.
There is no rising up.
He was a thorough going nonconformist.
He probably never joined any formal antislavery organization,
although we went to lots of their meetings.
He never joined a political party and we're not even sure if he ever voted.
He was a practitioner of what would become known in these years by certainly by
the 1850s of a kind of higher law doctrine about slavery and allegiance to God's
will and God's law above man's law.
Okay.
To John Brown,
put simply slavery represented and unjustifiable state of war.
Okay.
By one portion of the people against another and in the state of war.
You do what's necessary.
Okay.
Do defend yourselves.
Yeah.
He believes slavery was,
was an evil,
so entrenched and he was dead serious about this.
So entrenched in America that it required revolutionary ideology and
revolutionary means to eradicate it and it led to him as it has often in history
led most proponents of revolutionary violence that the means can therefore
justify the ends.
Okay.
As God had willed so often in his old testament that the wicked must die.
So to heady willed that slave holders and their defenders at least deserve the
same fate.
Okay.
John Brown came to believe that violence in a righteous cars was like a rite of
purification.
Uh,
what did he do
in brief?
John Brown's interest in Kansas was intense after the Kansas Nebraska Act.
He was living then by then in upstate New York,
uh,
up near what is today lake placid North Elbow,
which is indeed where he is buried.
Five of Brown sons went west to Kansas and late 1854 and early 1855.
There's an extraordinary exchange of letters between a couple of those sons
especially Oh and brown and his father back in New York,
letters that are saying things like,
father,
you must come out here with us.
There are slave holders living over on such and such a creek within two miles of
his father.
Violence is beginning to break out father.
And so the father came
okay.
And John Brown developed in Kansas by early 1855 by lady and 55 and in 1856 his
own little gorilla band,
they had gone to Kansas.
The fight in Kansas is border war.
Now I mentioned the other day that it was on,
it was in the spring of 1856 brown and his men are traveling along a roadway and
they get word of the beating of Charles Sumner on the floor of the Senate.
I think it was first told to them that summer was all but dead.
This to him,
great abolitionist,
Senator
and Brown,
it appears,
went into a frenzy and vowed revenge.
And a couple of days later he and four of his sons or three of his sons went and
did visitations at three houses along Pottawatomie creek and eastern Kansas,
known to be an area settled by slaveholders or pro slavery people.
And they dragged several men from their houses in front of their wives.
And hacked them to death five men to be exact,
hack them to death with these huge broad swords and deposited their bodies on
the front steps of their cabins.
This was the Pottawattamie creek massacre.
It touched off even greater violence in bleeding Kansas throughout that summer
into the fall of 1856
to John Brown.
He had kind of tried to even the score because just a few,
a couple of weeks before that pro slavery forces had sacked,
attacked,
and burned.
The antislavery capital of Kansas,
Lawrence,
Kansas burned the hotel and killed six people
brown by killing five said he hadn't quite even it up.
He spent the summer of 1856 in hiding.
No,
the fall
in October,
1856 he left Kansas and went back east to launch what became the harpers ferry
conspiracy,
and I'm in legal terms.
That's exactly what it was.
He launched a fundraising campaign to finance a new and more daring attempt to
take this war as he put it into Africa.
By that he meant the south.
It was his hope of attacking ultimately the largest federal arsenal in the
United States,
which was in Harper's ferry,
Virginia at the confluence of the shun and door and Potomac rivers,
just some 30 40 miles from Washington d c capture that largest federal arsenal
with its thousands of rifles and sidearms and barrels of gunpowder and
apparently launch a growing,
developing slave insurrection.
Okay.
Down through Virginia.
And it was his hope at least.
So the best we can understand
to engage in in effect a violent coup d'etat and take over the state of
Virginia.
No mic.
How long and dramatic story.
Short enough,
his fundraising campaign by 1857 fell by the way,
in part because of the panic of 1857 but he visited all over the north.
He visited the parlors of many famous abolitionist in New England.
He sat and Ralph Waldo Emerson study people hosted dinners for him.
He was this fascinating romantic,
somewhat bizarre old man was with hair that was whitening and had been out there
in Kansas raising hell.
They didn't all the details of the Pottawattamie creek massacre and even when
they began to hear them,
they didn't want to know too much,
but Brown was leading a crusade in Kansas to keep Kansas free soil.
Brown was doing in Kansas.
What a lot of these abolition is back east could not themselves do,
but they were glad he was doing it.
Began to raise some money for him.
He came down here to Connecticut and he ordered some 200 excuse me,
1000 spears.
He called him pikes from afford from a a forgery which are ultimately delivered
in boxes to a farm near Harper's ferry labeled famously Beecher's bibles,
huge heavy boxes,
labeled bibles
and then he went back west.
He established a headquarters in Tabor,
Iowa,
a town known to be settled by abolitionists from the east,
a place where he could begin to recruit men and train them.
Okay.
Then an early 1858 he spent one full month living in the attic apartment of
Frederick Douglass home in Rochester,
New York.
We have only one little letter they exchanged during that time.
It says,
John,
come down to dinner.
Thanks a lot guys.
But what we do know is that in that attic of Frederick Douglass House,
John Brown wrote his so called provisional constitution for the state of
Virginia.
When he took over Virginia,
he was going to announce a new constitution.
Okay?
He in fact was going to be the governor unless you had any doubt.
And then he called the convention in May,
1858 and Canada Chatham,
Ontario,
to which he invited abolitionist now black and white,
and it was to be a recruiting convention to recruit the men who would become
part of his abolitionist army.
Now the problem here with John Brown,
for everybody who met him,
including Douglas,
who may have known more about the harpers ferry plans in anybody alive,
the problem was he was so secret,
he would never tell people the details of what he was doing,
who he was actually hiring
46 so cold delegates,
one to this Chatham Convention,
13 of them white,
the rest of them blank.
Most of the people attending it were fugitive slaves living in Canada who had
escaped slavery in the United States,
many of whom still had family back in the south.
Here was a man in the midst of this political crisis going on in the country.
This is 50 is 1958 now,
who is saying,
I'm going to lead you back into the south and we're going to get your families
out.
He lacked money.
He had hired an unreliable drill master,
a guy named Hugh Forbes,
an English soldier of fortune,
who'd been off in Italy in the late forties and early 1850s kind of,
uh,
soldiering as a soldier of fortune and Garrett with Garibaldi in the Italian
revolution.
But it turns out it wasn't very reliable.
He got involved with a so called secret six of New England abolitionist time.
Doesn't really allow me to tell you everything about him,
but they were Franklin Sandborne.
Tom Is one where the Higgins and Theodore Parker,
Samuel Gridley,
how George Luther Sterns,
Garret Smith and others,
prominent,
powerful,
and in one case,
rich white,
New England and northern abolitionist who supported him.
Okay.
And then Brian went back out to Kansas that winter of 58
okay.
And in December of 58 with a band of about 13 men,
you want to cross the Kansas border in the Missouri dead of winter,
he attacked three farms,
or I suppose you could call them small plantations in Missouri
where he sees the 11 slaves killed one of the owners.
Yeah.
And then went back across the border into Kansas and hid out for a while.
And the debt of January,
okay.
How long?
Pottawatomie creek.
And then he engaged in an 82 day winter time,
trek of over 1000 miles with these 11 freed slaves from Kansas North into
Nebraska,
then into Iowa and to Grinnell,
Iowa,
by the way,
also settled by New England abolitionists.
And in Grinnell,
Iowa,
he was given a key to the city by a mayor
and in Grinnell where the,
the railroad had reached as far as Grinnell,
Iowa,
they put them all in a boxcar special box car.
Okay.
And they rode by train all the way to Chicago and then all the way to Detroit.
And on the 12th of March,
1859 it was a remarkable scene on the Detroit River as John Brown ushered these
11 freed slaves from Missouri across the river into Canada.
But at this point,
there was a 12th a baby had been born in the boxcar and mother had named him
John Brown Daniels.
So less we think this guy was
only a lunatic.
This was the real thing.
It freaks some slaves.
And he had carted them all across the northern states in the dead of winter
to their freedom.
To the extent he had a messianic image sense of himself as a Moses,
actually his greatest heroes,
Oliver Cromwell.
If you know anything about the English civil war and the puritan armies makes
sense.
It was based on something.
Now I only have a few minutes.
The Radon Harper's ferry would have actually happened a bit earlier.
It would have happened in the summer of 1859 had he been able to pull everything
together and get everybody to gather.
Uh,
and in the end,
it is one of those sad and tragic stories that then takes on a much,
much larger meaning than anyone could have ever predicted.
It's so called provisional army.
That's what he called for his provisional constitution for his provisional new
Virginia would ultimately be about 22 men.
He rented a farm five miles north of harpers ferry in Maryland,
where they're were all together that summer.
He wanted Frederick Douglass to join him.
He actually had met Harriet Tubman in Canada.
He tried to convince Harriet Tubman did join him.
He'd heard of her legend,
but she was a little too smart for this.
She'd done this stuff.
She had more experience and your friends' lives and getting them out then
anybody.
And she apparently said in effect,
no thanks.
He desperately wanted Douglas to join him.
And how'd he joined him?
Douglas would have been dead in 1859 but Douglas did have a final meeting with
John Brown at an old stone query outside of Chambersburg,
Pennsylvania.
And late August of 1859,
he went down from New York.
Well,
the fugitive slave Douglass had helped to his freedom.
Name Shields Green.
Here's shields.
Where is he?
There he is.
Douglas took him along.
They met at this old stone querying and Douglass his testimony.
They had a long conversation.
Brown tried one last time to talk Douglas into coming with me and Douglas and
his recollection famously said,
I can't do it.
You're going to be trapped in a how's he put it?
You're going to be surrounded in a trap of steel.
You will never get out,
but if you must go,
go.
And then he said,
does shields green your call,
your choice?
Well,
it turns off.
Shields Green was a fugitive slave from Virginia.
His wife was still in Virginia.
He said,
I,
according to Douglas,
I think I'll go with the old man.
And shields did and he'll die.
At Harper's ferry.
There were five black men.
Finally who join John Brown's raid,
Osborn,
Terry Anderson,
Dangerfield,
newbie shields,
green,
John Copeland,
Louis Leary,
two of them were Oberlin college graduates.
Three of them were former fugitive slaves.
Dangerfield.
Newbie had a letter in his pocket from his wife
in Virginia when he died at Harper's ferry.
The plan simply put so far as we know,
what's the attack?
Harper's ferry,
take the federal arsenal and begin if he could,
to escape into the mountains.
The of,
you know,
the Blue Ridge mountains on either side of harpers ferry
to establish mountain hideaways to try things from those hideaways to get slaves
to escape into his lines,
to arm them and then to begin as a guerrilla warrior to selectively attack sites
in northern Virginia.
Moving on Richmond.
Now I say to the extent we understand it,
cause he didn't leave us much to go on in terms of what his actual plan was.
What we do know is the rate only lasted 48 hours.
They never got out of harpers ferry.
He did free about a dozen slaves in the surrounding countryside,
brought them into the old fire engine house of the Federal Arsenal.
The harpers ferry hit out and the news sprung across the country.
Like news had never spread in the United States.
Partly because John Brown's first major strategic mistake or tactical mistake
was it the Manaca.
See Railroad came through Harper's ferry,
right as he was entering the town,
they stopped the train.
The first casualty was a free black watchmen on that train and was shot by one
of Brown's men.
Then Brown within two hours,
let the train go.
Dom Conductor of the train at the next town wired Washington and said,
one man and 200 men are attacking Harper's ferry.
By the time it reached Buchanan's desk in the White House,
it was 500 men attacking Harper's ferry
and within 24 hours,
Buchanan order to contingent of US Marines under the command of Robert E.
Lee and a lieutenant named Jeb Stewart to get to Harper's ferry as fast as
possible and crush the slave insurrection,
which they did.
Now I'm going to leave you there.
In this situation,
Brown was captured
all but two or three of his men were killed or captured and all those captured
will be hung.
One of his sons,
Owen Browne,
did manage to escape
what ensued at Harper's ferry for 24 hours.
It was an absolute pitch battle between the towns,
people,
local militias,
and Brown's men and many towns.
People were killed.
I want Brown would escape,
eventually move as far as far away as he possibly could and live on a little
desert farm up above Pasadena,
California.
Halfway up the San Gabriel mountains,
most of the rest of his life trying to escape the infamy of his father's legacy.
Brown was captured in the engine house.
They tried to run him through with a sword.
They beat him over the head.
They bloodied him up.
But there's the story goes,
he was saved by huge brass belt buckle he had and they kept stabbing at him and
I kept hitting the brass belt buckle.
He's captured,
put in jail in Charles town,
Virginia,
just four miles up the road.
And in November,
1859,
he would get the most famous,
uh,
sensational trial that the United States had ever seen.
I'm going to leave you there because it's the John Brown hanging in execution
and the aftermath that is the most important template of that election year of
1860.
Soon to come.